un edificio residencial en ruinas en
kiev la más reciente víctima de los
bombardeos rusos
mientras las sirenas de ataque aéreos
sonaban en la capital el viernes por la
mañana los residentes se vieron
obligados a refugiarse bajo tierra en
las afueras de la ciudad había una nube
de humo cuando las tropas rusas tomaron
el control del aeropuerto internacional
antonov después de abalanzarse con
helicópteros y aviones que venían desde
la dirección de belarús a más de 500
kilómetros de distancia en la madrugada
del viernes un ataque con misiles golpeó
un puesto fronterizo ucraniano en la
región sureste de sap orilla matando e
hiriendo a algunos guardias las tropas
rusas y los tanques pesados habían
llegado desde el este el jueves por la
mañana a las regiones de harkov lugansk
y el este de charlie goff y desde el sur
desembarco por mar en las ciudades dio
desa y mariupol a medida que avanzaba el
día cayó la central eléctrica de
chernóbil en la frontera con belarús
desafortunadamente tengo que informar
que a partir de ahora la zona de
chernóbil toda la planta de energía
nuclear de chernóbil han sido tomadas
bajo el control de grupos militares
rusos no hay víctimas según la zona de
exclusión de chernóbil y la planta de
energía nuclear
pronto se supo que el personal de la
planta estaba siendo tomado como rehén
lo que provocó una enérgica respuesta de
washington sugiriendo que ucrania fue
solo el comienzo de los planes de
cutting
ciertamente pensamos que tiene mayores
ambiciones más allá de ucrania
algunos de los combates más intensos del
jueves tuvieron lugar en la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol según los informes
aún no ha caído en manos rusas